[Music]
i don't really have that good of a
natural spatial geometric sense you're i
think you're supposed to if you're a
mathematician it's like sort of those
things are supposed to be associated but
just looking up or sort of outside the
building when i work my office is in
there somewhere
but where it is i could not tell you i
go in there every day for 15 years but
like whether it's on this side of the
building or the other side of the
building or like whether it be down
there or over there i
i truly have no idea
when i first learned geometry um i
didn't care for it it didn't suit me and
i think maybe that was part of it i
think it was only once i started to
understand that algebra and numbers and
geometry under the skin were the same
that they could be combined and sort of
work together that was my way in
i still don't know where my office is if
i'm inside i can find it don't worry
i know the number that's that's how i
find it
[Music]
geometry is everywhere any kind of game
whether it's checkers or tic-tac-toe or
connect 4 or chess or go or whatever the
game itself has its geometry and when
you train a machine to play that game
you're training the machine to explore
that geometry and that geometry is the
geometry of a tree a tree depending on
which one you look at it has a trunk and
that trunk branches into smaller
branches and the small branches branch
into smaller branches and etc etc etc
but you can never go back right that's
the way a game works that's the way any
kind of linearly sequenced set of
decisions works it's the treeness of the
geometry that makes those games solvable
that's what makes it possible for there
to be a literally perfect strategy which
is what we now have in computer checkers
so you can you know you can play against
the computer it's just sitting there at
the university of alberta running all
day and night and you can log in
and play against it at some point
usually it takes about three or four
moves for me because i don't really know
checkers very well it'll just be like i
have one
if what you know about geometry is like
ninth grade
it doesn't seem like it could be very
dangerous but there's like a long
history of seeing it that way geometry
kind of creates a new locus of authority
that's not
under political control and lots of
people see that as a threat i mean this
question about drawing legislative
districts which is such a hot political
topic here in wisconsin somebody's got
to kind of sit down and cut wisconsin
into 99 parts it seems like a technical
exercise but it actually has a huge
effect on who's sitting in the
legislature who's making the laws and in
particular who draws the next set of
lines so there's kind of a feedback
if you're like me right if you're
training math at first you're like okay
so there's a math question here like
what's the right way it's not a math
question but it's not not a math
question the math is wound up with these
political questions with legal questions
which are obviously really important but
also with fundamentally philosophical
questions because what you're really
saying is what would be fair i don't
think you can answer that without doing
some philosophy but i think if you try
to approach a question like that without
doing any calculation without doing any
geometry at all i think that your
answers are always going to be like
a little bit flabby and unstructured
that's kind of a deep idea and of course
it's one that one is drawn to is a
mathematician that the geometry
which
unfortunately so many people experience
as like
i don't want to say prison but like
you know some place that they have to be
actually can be kind of a liberatory
activity
[Music]
[Music]
you